weather news now and Iranian President
Abraham rayec has arrived in Uganda as
part of a three-country tour of Africa
right you see recognized kampala's
recent approval of anti-gay legislation
and criticized Western countries for
supporting homosexuality
it's the first visit by an Iranian
leader to Uganda for more than 10 years
well earlier right you see visited the
Kenyan Capital where trade talks with
President William Ruto tops the agenda
Catherine Sawyer has this from Nairobi
Iran's president Ibrahim rice he chose
Kenya at his first stop of his
three-country tour of Africa
the main focus is trades
President William Ruto and rice is
signed several agreements on
communication technology agriculture
mining tourism and education this
memoranda will enhance and further
deepen our bilateral relations for
sustainable growth and development
between our two countries it's not just
a bilateral relations here also there
are grounds for for relation with
different African counters are provided
here it's a better ground words at the
volume of trade
between two countries is not at an it's
not an acceptable none of us is
satisfied
the visit comes at a time when ricey is
eager to form new alliances Iran has
stepped up its diplomacy in recent
months after years of Western sanctions
led to economic and political isolation
it may be marking the beginning of the
end of what I call Iranian African
isolation that has been ongoing in part
because of the western sanctions that
were imposed on Iran the president was
expected
arrive on Tuesday but that was canceled
and pushed to Wednesday this newspaper
article says that that was not a
coincidence some diplomats were
uncomfortable about the visits either
way people see ruto's foreign policy
remains Pro West with the transition and
the election of the new president in
Kenya I think the new president has
seems to be taking a rather radical
shift and considering what the economy
is going through with the country is
going through the current president
seems to be giving Primacy the issue of
national interest as opposed to the
geopolitical calculations that are going
on around the world trade will also
likely dominate the agenda in Uganda and
Zimbabwe after he is Kenyan visit both
countries are facing economic
difficulties with Zimbabwe also facing
economic sanctions Catherine soy Al
Jazeera Nairobi Kenya all right let's
look into the story a little bit more
and introduce Abdul rasool devsala who's
a visiting professor at the catalica
University and a scholar on Iran's
foreign policy he joins us live from
Rome a warm welcome to the NewsHour so
president raisi called Africa a
continent of opportunities and a great
platform for Iranian products why then a
decade-long delay since the last
high-level visit for by Iran
uh thank you for having me first uh well
that's a good question I think uh
president rice he wants to reset Iran's
relation with Africa basically that
means uh he's trying to distance himself
with what his and uh president
um Rouhani did which was a somehow a
full neck uh neglecting of African uh
African capacities in Iran's foreign
policy so I think uh what race is
actually doing is not a kind of a
hegemonic or necessarily anti-western uh
issue well I think there are been some
learnings from ahmadine job period which
uh using
um anti-western realtoric which actually
not helped Iran Africa relation instead
this time I think the emphasize of the
Iranian side is more on trade and and
possible collaborations on various
sectors which might be interest for Iran
especially on uh to improve its
exporting actually export capacity
actually what is happening is is that
this should be seen in a broader uh in a
broader picture of Iran's foreign policy
shift which is Shifting basically from
West toward the global South and the
East uh you know that Ibraham race is
emphasis in foreign policy was a
neighborhood on building ties with China
and Russia and now going to Africa so
these are all components around shift to
Global South given the shift from the
West to the global South why these
specific countries Kenya Uganda Zimbabwe
what's the driving force behind this
trip to those specific Nations
well actually there have been many other
contacts there have been lots of uh
diplomatic
let's say movements in Tehran with other
African countries uh and and I think
these three probably the the the trip is
arranged because they might have better
uh trade and economic opportunities to
work with Iran you know Iranians are
looking for the possibility of exporting
their services and are seeing that as
part of the uh the capacity to let's say
evade sanctions which uh which they're
suffering um under under U.S and
international sanctions so there are
some serious economic motives on that
but it's important to notice that these
these countries are the ones that race
is traveling but that doesn't mean that
uh Iran's diplomacy other African
countries uh is uh is lagging you know
you're you know that Iran is trying to
rebuild its relation with Egypt uh Al
jazeeren Algerian foreign minister was
in are on a few weeks ago so basically
there are lots of activities right going
on with other African countries right at
this point now given Iran remains as you
say under heavy U.S economic sanctions
of course it seems fairly logical to
want to find other markets and Forge
other Partnerships elsewhere in the
world but in doing so do these specific
African countries risk losing or
undermining their ties with the US I'm
thinking especially Kenya a key Ally of
the United States
well that very much depends how
iranian's position themselves I think if
it's just about a trade
um well there are uh ways to to thwart
that risk uh but if Iran goes back to
its uh sort of Ahmadinejad period type
of policy which was it's African
um let's say uh policy was very much
framed along the the you know
anti-western uh real terrorist that was
toxic because actually it caused it puts
African countries to choose between Iran
and the West so it very much depends how
Iranians frame their relation with the
Africa my understanding is that at this
point Iranians are very much looking at
the private sector export to uh to to
Africa uh to none probably necessarily
governmental ties if you see at the type
of the agreements that are uh that are
there on the table and they've been been
signed you realize that it's the
emphasis very much on small trade export
sort of services and technology and and
those areas which which can have some
solutions uh in order to not be under
the sanction remember that still despite
the sanctions Iran has a huge trade with
the United Arab Emirates which is
actually a close Ally of the United
States in the region so basically it
very much depends on how Iran position
itself in what sectors and in what areas
the two sides can manage to to uh to
channel the relation
visiting professor at the Catalina
University uh very uh grateful to have
you on the show many thanks
thank you for having me